I can't leave home without my watch I
need it every even even if I'm not
wearing it I have to put it in the case
and bring it with me coz if you go into
a store and you look like me I look like
a hobo
so they need like a reason to talk to me
so I just put my lights on and I'll be
like hey could you help me or something
my manager pitched in and got me this
for my birthday which is super tight it
was my first gift in Rowley this is
happy 21st Asti Dre super cute these are
my favorites right now cuz it's a
statement piece it's very tight it's
Hello Kitty I got two Hello kitties this
one is running and this one it's just a
face I wear it cuz the girl stick is
really cute they always give me a lot of
comments like oh my god you so I had
something Wow I got this at a Webster in
Miami and I saw it and I liked it and I
was like okay let me get that she
charged my card and I was like 175 bucks
Wow forever a said yeah this one's the
biggest one this one is the second
biggest I did this one is the smallest
one and I like to wear more when I was
15 and finally had the money to do I
ordered a kid off the internet so you
press your teeth into it you get the
imprint and send it back and then they
send the teeth to you it wasn't cool
enough so I went I went to a guy from
Toronto in Toronto grills and he redid
this for me and made some nice gold
teeth it
whenever you get home you take them off
it feels so good but you got to look
cool somehow